- On ne peut rien changer sans
un peu indisposer des gens.
Il s'agit de le faire de la
meilleure manière possible.
- C'était en 2016, André Arthur
tentait un ultime  la
radio de Québec, en promettant
du bout des lèvres d'éviter les
dérapages. Moins de deux ans
plus tard, il perdait son micro
dans la foulée de propos jugés
homophobes.
CLAUDE THIBODEAU
ancien patron d'André Arthur
- Tu ne contrôlaré
Arthur! Trop fier, trop bucké,
trop talentueux. Mettez le
qualificatif de votre choix!
- Au lendemain du décès de
l'ex-animateur, Claude Thibodeau
se souvient d'un homme
impossible à diriger, mais aussi
municateur d'exception.
C'est dans les années
80 qu'André Arthur atteint
des sommets de popularité
à l'antenne de CHRC.
Son style sans compromis et sa
fameuse tribune téléphonique en
font un favoris des auditeurs.
- Ok, maintenant, c'est assez,
répondez à ma question.
- Quelle question?
- Bonne journée, madame.
Oui, bonOui, bonOui, bonOui, bo!
- Selon Alain Dufresne,
André Arthur a rompu avec
le ton p des
animateurs de l'époque.
L'animateur s'appuyait aussi
sur ses connaissance quasi
encyclopédiques de l'histoire
et de l'actualité.
- Arthur était doté d'une
mémoire atomique. C'est
incroyable comme il a réussi
à mémoriser autant de faits sur
autant d'événements avec autant
de précision.
- Mais les controverses et les
excès de langage ne sont jamais
loin avec Arthur.
- As-tu vu celui qui ressemble à
une carpe? Une carpe japonaise?
Une grosse gueule de suceux, là.
- Au fil de sa carrière, il sera
poursuivi des dizaines de fois.
En 2003, l'ex-animateur de radio
Robert-Gillet intente unepoursur
diffamation, avant d'accepter
une entente à l'amiable.
En 2006, André Arthur réussit le
tour de e faire élire
comme indépendant au Parlement
fédéral. Réélu en 2008, il sera
finalement emporté par la vague
orange de 2011, qui voit le NPD
gagner 59 sièges au Québec.
JOËL GODIN, député, PCC
Portneuf - Jacques-Cartier, Qc
- André Arthur, merci d'avoir
servi, b
(applaudissements)
- Tout au long de sa carrière,
André Arthur n'aura laisséperso.
Ici Olivier Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, Qué